hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that was played
yesterday it was the opening ceremony of
the grantchester that will be played in
Croatia starting today at starting today
we will have three or three rounds of
Rapid of course then we will have three
days of Rapid nine rounds overall and
then two days of Blitz which means uh 18
runs of Blitz but before that there was
an opening ceremony there was a
simultaneous exhibition where all of the
players of the grand Chester took on I
don't know how many players there were
but usually it's somewhere between 20
and 40. but it's not uh the usual type
of a simultaneous exhibition where you
will have let's say Magnus cars and he
will hold a simultaneous exhibition
against 40 players here all of the
participants of the grand Chester here
that are playing in Zagreb are
simultaneously holding a simultaneous
exhibition against all of them so Magnus
will make the first move then alireza
will make the second one and will make
the third move and then they just walk
around and then they make all of the
moves and joining them and here okay I'm
just gonna show you who the players are
that were participating so yeah it is
so the 10 of them were playing the
simultaneous exhibition simultaneously
against everyone participating and also
they were joined by none other than
former world champion Gary Kasparov uh
as he is uh well whenever there's a
chess event in Croatia you can expect
that's part of to be there uh so that's
why I didn't write Magnus Carlsen below
his photo it's actually the grand
Chester team and Gary Kasparov and of
course their combined reigning is well
over nine thousand uh and I would put
more photos there but I only have room
for one so I put Magnus as he is the
highest rated one uh so that being said
we are going to check out the game it's
it's really a spectacular game because
well you might not expect it but Ivano
actually defeated them he won this game
brilliantly with the black pieces and uh
okay yeah he's been playing chess for
quite a while he is the under 11
creation uh champion and he he's an
incredible player currently his rating
is in 1935 he said himself that he feels
that he could maybe uh get it
to be a bit higher and once you see his
play uh you will definitely believe that
so yeah he plays uh I've seen an
interview with him uh he he says that he
plays pretty much from the time he wakes
up he even plays a little bit and
studies before school he says he's a
little bit addicted to chess but that he
loves it and that he will uh probably
you know enjoy it for as long as
possible and here okay if you guys want
uh this is Sim this is him last year uh
in the opening of the grand Chester he
made the first move uh for for the
Magnus game here you have gukesh making
a move against him there you see the
setting of The simultaneous exhibition
there's nipple also making a move
against him
uh there's okay there's Magnus Carlson
also making a move against them so like
I said all of the players of the grand
Chester plus Gary cast power there's
even Charice uh uh also this could even
be the end of the game but no I think
it's actually the first move uh so
there's a Constantin lupolesco uh there
you have it alireza also making the
first movie van or preparing to play
Rook 8 to d8 as you'll see in the game
Anand also shaking his hand um uh
finally reaching the board so uh
whenever the player reaches the board
and they still haven't made a move they
shake hands of course uh and then they
make the first move there's casparov so
yeah everyone is there it's gonna be
it's gonna be a great game obviously
because power of made the first move so
let's check it out quite the game uh as
you as you'll see so uh the the
grantchester team has the white pieces
and they open uh with Pawn to D4 uh
kasparo was the one who opened I believe
as we've seen now in the photos uh we
have Knight to F6 by Ivano upon the C4
E6 and now Knights to F3 going for the
anti-nimzo and usually when you see an
antonym so we will probably just
transpose into some sort of a D5 Knight
to C3 and Bishop to B4 that are goes in
defense which is perfectly fine for both
white and black but Ivano plays the more
active the BOGO Indian defense which is
like the nimzo only white of course is
not forced to play Knight to C3 here
which was which would transpose into an
I2 F3 Nim so white plays Knight B to D2
and this is what the grand Chester team
goes for uh we have Pawn to B6 and now
Pawn to A3 chasing away the bishop and
not just Bishop captures on D2 there are
some games where Bishop to E7 was played
but it's extremely rare uh for example
uh jobava played it against kariakin but
he lost the game short played against
karwana he also lost the game it's
incredibly rare So Bishop capture sandy2
is the main line with Bishop captures
and now uh the top moves for black are
Bishop to B7 this is the the absolute
top move okay H6 has been played quite a
lot Knights the E4 is a known move uh
but uh Ivano plays Ponte A5 and here you
see just how much he understands just he
fights against White's B4 move and that
is uh that is absolutely essential here
it has been played before only a handful
of times uh you know in top T in top
level competition black never actually
won a game playing this move last time
uh Coachman played it against gelfand in
Odessa in 2007 and he lost that game but
okay let's see uh What uh Ivano had in
mind obviously he prepared something
very rare for the grand Chester team we
have Pawn to G3 makes sense of course
they want to think up to their Bishop on
this long diagonal Ivana does the same
Bishop to G2 and now there is a game
where castles must play but here we have
Pawn to D6 and it is now as of move 8
that we have a completely new game so
here we have castles Knight beta D7
nicely continuing development we have
Rook to C1 and Ivano castles we have
rooked the E1 and the queen to E7 now
developing the queen preparing to bring
the Rooks into the game with Bishop to
C3 also nicely putting in the bishop on
this diagonal and now Rook 8 to V8 that
makes sense the queen is still on D1 if
you want to place the let's say E5 then
the position opens up this will be very
good for him uh but of course uh the
players uh do not allow this they play
Pawn to D5 and now Ivano has to make a
choice does he go Knight to C5 does he
go Knights the E5 does he go Knight to
E4 that's the capture on D5 what's the
idea behind captures on D5 why did uh
why did the grandchester team even play
this D5 move well the point is after he
captures on D5 as Ivano did play this
Knight to H4 simply opening up the light
Square Bishop's diagonal and now you
cannot capture another Pawn the bishop
and B7 would hang so how can you
continue this well Ivano actually a very
cool-headed plays the absolute best move
plays Queen to E6 he says I will just
defend my Pawn on D5 and you show me why
this is so good and here comes the first
imprecision of the grand Chester team
and here the problem I believe for them
is that they were playing all of them
were playing one game so they couldn't
really decide on a plan and Ivana was
playing his own game so he uh pretty
much played the absolute best move for
14 entire game and here the best move
for for the grand Chester team would
just be to trade everything Bishop
captures an F6 and then at some point
you will capture the C7 Pawn that's
pretty much it Knight captures on F6 C
captress on D5 Bishop captures and D5
Bishop uh first Rook captures on C7 of
course Bishop captures and G2 Rook a
king captures or Knight captures then
Rook to C8 and at some point let's say
queen to C2 you double up here but now
Knight to D5 will force a trade on the C
file captures captures and Ivano would
win the C file but equal material
uh it's pretty much uh an equal game
okay he does have the uh the isolated D
Pawn but nothing uh really happening uh
here so it would be perfectly fine
however after this queen the E6 moved
the grand Chester team decided for Queen
to C2 and now he just goes Knight to E4
and here black is already better there's
no way for white to get his Pawn back
and there's no way to actually create
some sort of an active counter play uh
here they played C captress on D5 Bishop
captures on D5 and now uh we have Bishop
to D4 here uh how do you continue you're
down upon you don't have active play the
the bishop here is suffering on C3 the
Knight can always capture it however you
play this Diwana will just straight down
and be up a pawn even with the absolute
best move B4 from White which I know is
always the best move let's say captures
captures Knight captures and C3 Queen
captures Bishop captures and G2 Knight
captures Now Pawn to C5 Ivana will
create a pass pawn and he will be the
one pushing for the win here so Bishop
to D4 was played not allowing this trade
but now Ivano just plays Pawn to C5 he
pushes the bishop back and now well you
could push the bishop back right away I
mean no self-respecting Grand Master
will repeat the move uh and go back to
where he came from uh they uh try
complicating they play Pawn to F3 and
now Ivana just goes back Knight E to F6
they also go back Bishop to C3 and now
Bishop to B3 grabbing that uh uh B3 D1
diagonal forcing the White Queen to go
back we have Queen to B1 and now Pawn to
D5 Now Pawn to D4 is coming and how are
you stopping those pawns they play Pawn
to E3 which stops spawn to D4 but now
Pawn to G6 we have Pawn to F4 this Pawn
to F4 move
uh okay it's it's not a move you want to
play but what else is there for white
do they even have a move he completely
paralyzed the uh the entire board so
they play Ponte for this opens up uh
this Bishop's diagonal but they also
weaken the E4 and G4 squares and Ivano
immediately uh plants a knight on e4 so
94 and now while you could go for
something like Knight to F3 and try to
hold a passive position they go for the
attack Pawn to F5 and Ivano just ignores
it he plays Queen to E7 uh very nicely
done with Rook to F1 now with ideas of
maybe you can capture the Knight here
and then play Pawn to F6 and then maybe
somehow Checkmate the black king uh
Ivano just plays Knight D to F6 uh he
doesn't allow that and he asks what what
are you playing now so they played F
captures on G6 and well you could play
something safe like H captors and G6
Ivana goes for the more active approach
F captures and G6 now he opens up the f
file for his rook and uh he asks what uh
what will they even play at this point
I'm sure okay he was uh probably under
the impression that he was playing
against the absolute best players in the
world but on the other hand I'm pretty
sure he felt a very very confident in
his position here and now again uh best
uh for white is to trade here for
example Bishop captures Rook captures
Rook captures uh Queen captures and now
Rook to F1 let's say queen to E6 but
still no problems for black black will
still just continue pushing the pawns
and not a lot for white to look for here
so instead they tried keeping the
tension they played Rook to F4 and now
we have Rook Dita E8 now the E3 Pawn is
a weakness once the Knight moves how
will uh the players wielding the white
pieces defend this so they play Queen to
D3 but now just Bishop to C4 pushing the
White Queen further back we have Queen
to D1 and now finally eliminating this
powerful Bishop which is pretty much
White's only good piece uh Knight
captures on C3 Rook captures and now uh
look at this Ponte a for now this is a
true true tile move this is a really a
beautiful attacking move uh you know
someone who would want to slow play this
would probably go B5 and then A4 but not
Ivano he's a true attacker and he goes
A4 right away and now the idea is okay
why what's not just capture the A4 Pawn
uh what is um what's his plan well his
plan is that he wants to play G5 but you
can play right away the problem is the
Knight can come to F5 with tempo attack
the queen then you can just move the
rook and also you would weaken your king
side and you don't want the White Queen
having
um uh well such an easy way of reaching
the king side so the idea is that uh
after Pawn to A4 well you could capture
it Queen captures an A4 uh he would play
Queen to E6 not allow Knight five to
come with Tempo now he's preparing G5
and it's not gonna be uh and it's not
gonna be easy uh playing this it would
be incredibly difficult to actually pick
up this Pawn uh it's even hard to find
the move here for white you probably
have to go back or or something you
would have to okay you could pick it up
upon maybe you give up the exchange uh
hard to find an active uh move for white
here so instead after this A4 move they
decided not to touch the pawn they
played Knight to F3 and now Ivana just
plays Bishop to B3 continues uh mounting
the pressure we have Queen to E1 and now
of course Pawn to D for the queen and E1
is undefended okay it's defended by the
Knight but it's the D1 square is also
being attacked twice so Rook the C1 and
now Queen captures on E3 no funny
business here Ivan is already up upon
now he wins another one and he is of
course uh well very confident that he
will win this queen captures with not D
captures you could play D captures but
you already have the D1 Square covered
so it makes sense to keep the pawn on
the D file so Rook captures an E3 and
now Knight to D2 trying to get rid of
this nasty Bishop
uh we have rooked the E2 okay uh talk
speaking of nasty Bishops you guys
requested in the previous video where I
uh said unleash the Bish that I should
make some unleash the Bish merchandise I
actually made some it's the first link
in the description below do check it out
if you uh if you would like to acquire
some unleash the Bish merch I will only
keep it up for a month so uh you know
starting August it will be it will be
gone uh Rook the E2 was played and now
Knight captures on B3 we have a capture
some B3 and now Rook C to F1 doubling up
on the f file putting pressure on the
Knight on F6 uh but here imagine this
even though it seems like there's so
much to play for probably you guys are
expecting okay uh Ivano it does have a
better position he's up to pawns but
he's playing an end game against these
monsters these uh 20 27 50 2800 players
surely there's no way for him to
actually win this game well no he played
King to G7 and he was in this position
on move 36 that the grandchester team
resigned as their truly is nothing more
to be done here their position is so
helpless that they decided not even to
continue here uh as uh well it's best
for me to just show you why it's uh why
it's so helpless now there's no good
defense against uh moves like uh c c for
C3 B5 and those pawns are just marching
forward and if you try to even look for
an active plan with white let's say you
play Pawn to G4 you want to chase away
the knights then maybe do something uh
G5 can be played and okay let's say Rook
to F5 Pawn to H6 okay white wants to
break through you have to play active
moves let's say H4 G captures an H4 you
can even play G5 let's say h captors
through captures now okay you've gained
some activity here but after King to H6
and now Rook G to F5 the problem is you
can even ignore the Knight you can play
Rook captures on B2 that's just how much
ivana's position is better
and even after the speech sacrifice
let's say real characters Rook captures
Rook captures and King to G5 there's no
way to stop all of these pawns let's say
We'll capture some B6 D3 is coming now
let's say King to F1 you try to bring
the king to help out C4 is coming you
play Rook to C6 to stop the C Pawn now
Rook the C2 now the B and the D pawns
are coming if you play Rook the B6 knock
point to B2 is coming now if you play
Bishop to F3 or really doesn't matter
the king cannot escape from the back
rank you will play Pawn to C3 oh sorry
not quantity to pawn to C3 uh if Bishop
to e form doesn't matter Rook the C1
check if King F2 you will play Pawn to
D2 so the the pawns are unstoppable it's
merely a matter of how you want to win
this uh pretty much every move is
winning here for black let's say Rook to
D6 D1 uh becomes a queen you will have
to give up your Rook now it's Rook
against bishop and two connected past
pawns and after something like King Day
3 you will play H3 even the H Pawn
marches forward let's say Pawn to A4 you
will play a rook to D2 and after
something like A5 you will play Pawn to
H2 after A6 you will bring another queen
into the game let's say Bishop captures
now you will play B1 Queen and now of
course you get checkmate at A7 and queen
to D3 will be Checkmate so this is only
one of the uh ways you you could win
this end game but the the grand Chester
players of course realized that there is
no point in playing this so they just
resigned this and what a I mean what a
badass way for young ivanot uh uh the
the force resignation from the the
absolute best players in the world just
King G7 he says my knight is defended
you you have nothing here and I mean
they resigned
so yeah I mean first I thought okay it's
probably I I mean or sometimes it
happens that uh you know the underdog
defeats the Grand Master in a
simultaneous exhibition but here he did
not just beat them he absolutely crushed
them they made two slight imprecisions
uh throughout the entire game so like we
mentioned okay he prepared this A5 line
which is a bit rare uh and okay he
obviously had some ideas of what he
wanted to play but here
after after they attempted this D5
breakthrough and Knight to H4 after
Queen to E6 they just didn't find a way
on how to continue Bishop captures and
F6 is the only way which gives them an
active position but after Queen to C2 uh
and this Knight to E4 move it was just
Ivano for the entire game so there was
no way of actually reclaiming that pawn
back and he just squeezed squeezed
squeezed uh until they they resigned I
mean there was uh he he played this this
game like like like like a merger of
like tal and Petrosian uh you know and
Fisher which is basically Magnus Carlsen
himself so I mean uh absolute absolutely
spectacular after akin to G7 they
resigned and I I think this is one
victory that Ivano will remember for a
long time and I'm sure you guys agree
agree with him that maybe he could even
improve his rating to be a bit higher
than 1935. uh so yeah that's the game
hope you uh hope you guys enjoyed it
will be following what happens in the
grand Chester Croatia being played in
zaga if some of you are there in Zagreb
I don't mind it's like 60 kilometers
from where I live if if you guys want to
you know play some games take some
photos I don't mind showing up you know
maybe having a beer or two if you're
there you know just send me an email
yeah if they're they're like uh a bunch
of you interested I I will definitely
come uh so yeah once again really hope
you guys enjoyed it if you would uh
enjoy purchasing the uh unleash the Bish
merch it will be the first link in the
description below and yeah we'll be
following uh imana's progress uh I mean
uh if you can do this against the
absolute best Elite in the world
definitely the sky is the limit so very
much looking forward to where it takes
him I would like to thank James Eugene
Cashman Josh Stanton and not complete
the bullet just thriller.com Paul Miller
uh for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day